measles cases have surged worldwide this
year amid disruption caused by covid19
the un has warned that the increase
suggests outbreaks of other diseases are
likely to be on the way who better to
talk to about this or let me show you a
couple of graphics 79 in the first two
months of the year compared to the year
before
as i was saying dr dave navarro is with
us now the whole special envoy for the
global covert 19 response and in
addition to that um obviously you've got
a view on what's happening as far as the
measles are concerned
i know that you have young people in the
family don't you how concerned should we
be
well
you know modern life is about
using modern science
to keep ourselves healthy and safe and
vaccination against the common illnesses
of childhood is one of the absolute
basics of modern life
and we've got really good vaccination
programs all over europe to keep kids
safe one of them is the vaccination
program against measles but it's been
slowed down because kovid has really
taken up so much of health care and so
we've got an awful lot of people who've
missed out on measles vaccination 73
million throughout the world and that's
meant that this year
in the first few months there have been
17 000 cases of measles globally whereas
in the first two months of the previous
years it's usually been lower 10 000 or
less so yes we've got a global
measles epidemic
and that worries us because
measles can be a very dangerous disease
we just got to get the vaccinations
working again and that's part of getting
health services working again as covid
settles into a more regular position in
our lives okay so what do we need to do
as parents grandparents to try to
protect our kids apart from giving them
the inoculation
yeah i'm sorry about that yes well i
mean i think
it did we've learned a lot about keeping
ourselves and our kids safe and the
value of hygiene the value of actually
not going to nursery or to school if
you're sick if you can be kept at home
all that does reduce infection and then
secondly of course i do want to stress
about immunization i know you said it
but a lot of folk have actually thought
to themselves well with all this fuss
and bother about kobe perhaps we won't
take our kids to be immunised in any way
it's quite difficult because doctor
surgeries have been using uh different
working arrangements so that is my main
request to everybody please
get your child vaccinated please talk to
the local nurse or doctor about
vaccination options it really matters
it's so so important and with measles
the more people who get vaccinated the
more likely we are to get that the whole
measles outbreaks under control
okay and just before i let you go what
else are we concerned about as far as
diseases viruses that our kids might
catch and spread
well um thank you i mean
there have been reports of of other
conditions emerging liver conditions and
so on and what i've noticed is that most
of the worries are related to the fact
that our health services and our lives
have been so disrupted by kovid so my
basic point to everybody is as things
gets going again please get back into
the rhythm of getting regular checkups
for your child's health and for your own
health
if that can work because it really
matters that whole preventive health
care is key to our collective future and
i'm just going to say okay that covid
has not gone away so i am going to ask
everybody keep a lookout for if it comes
back again surging back into your
communities don't throw away those masks
get them out again and be ready to put
them on because kovid does have a habit
of coming back and masks and physical
distancing are really important
protectors
i'll let you go we've only got 30
seconds left on the show but how i would
be remiss of me not to ask about otto
okay my otto is fabulous up and walking
well and with his brother isaac he's
just absolutely one of the bright boys
of brill near aylesbury what a what a
what a village and what a beautiful
place i hope they're having a sunny
morning
i'm sure he is the brightest little boy
that anybody's ever seen in the whole
world that's right that's okay
it's good to talk to you as always
doctor thank you so much for joining us
on the program thank you